all right now this is sad um and this is
you know we've always tried to handle
this issue with like uh tact on this
show because a lot of people don't
I don't want to live in a right-wing a
Christian theocracy this is not what I
want to live in here's what I also don't
want
um what I don't want is uh
children
um you know
using
puberty blocking hormones
or having surgery
uh and then possibly later in life
really regretting that or saying you
know what I never knew what could have
been because I made these choices when I
was very young there seems to be a rush
um that children that are trans or
feeling like they are trans and have
some type of uh you know dysphoria
potentially are being rushed into
operating rooms or they're being rushed
in the doctor's offices gender
reassignment clinics and stuff like that
I do think that there's a rutwood it's a
little bit of a rush it's a rush
you know I've always I've always come
from the perspective of like when you're
you can do whatever you want
uh you know
within reason if we can ship you off to
war if you can vote if you can do all
these things you should be able to
change your gender if you like this is
really sad though because there are this
was an 18 year old and unfortunately
stuff happens uh even at that age
because now I agree that this person
should have been allowed to do this but
this is a this is a tragic death one of
the participants in a Dutch study
um
it's really sad 18 year old trans
identified male whose puberty was
blocked by the Dutch researchers at a
very early stage meaning there wasn't
enough penile tissue for surgeons to use
to create the new Vagina therefore a
more risky procedure using a section of
the patient's bowel was necessary which
resulted in
necrotizing fasciitis which is a
flesh-eating bacteria
um
and by the way
and I'm not trying to take a side here
in the culture War but this is
the plot of Frozen three
and I don't understand why
because the plot of Frozen three
is about someone who
sadly tragically dies because their
bowel vagina
got diseased
I thought Frozen was about snowmen and a
nice uh castle princess queen thing
but it's not
it's about someone's bowel
being made into a vagina
and that vagina got diseased and they
died
and that's Frozen three
so maybe
I don't think it's funny
that children who go to see who's in
Olaf
the Snowman have to sit through a
two-hour movie
about a vagina being made out of
someone's bowel because they don't have
penile tissue because their puberty was
blocked in a young a this is the I'm not
lying this is Frozen three
and I just think it's it's too much for
kids to deal with at this time
you can be whatever you want to be but
if you don't have enough penal tissue
because we blocked your puberty we're
gonna use your bowel that's the thing
that you used to go to the bathroom and
we're gonna make a vagina but it might
get sick
that that's one of the songs and by the
way I don't even think that as a song I
don't think that's well written
I don't think that's well written I'm a
fan of alliteration and metaphor and
it's that's very direct
and it's unfortunate
this is not right that this happened
because now I guess in a few years are
going to be better at this isn't that
the hope
isn't that the hope
in a few now this is a fair question
don't get mad at me the question is in a
few years are we going to be better at
bowel vagina surgeries yes or no
are we going to be better at making a
vagina out of someone's bowel I hope we
are literally not kidding no joke I
genuinely hope getting a vagina in a few
years is like nothing
it's like remember the dentist was kind
of annoying that's what I hope it is I
don't want anybody dying if you want a
vagina they should be able to give you a
[__] puss and it should be quick and
it's gonna be what it what will it be at
that point 20 20 30 25 20 27 20 30. in
2030 if you're dying because they can't
put a puss on you
we got a problem
so they need to figure this out
without people getting necrotizing for
shitis
and I don't think it should be
the plot of Frozen three because now in
Frozen three they lie and at the end
uh the necrotizing fasciitis is cured by
the magic of the land which isn't real
that's not real
but at the end the the bowel vagina is
cured and the person is free
what do you mean Jesus this is the plot
of the film this was leaked from Disney
leaked to this I don't even know why
they leaked this I think because they
want to have the fight now
what if Disney had a ride called bowel
vagina the ride
where kids could see because here's the
deal this it's it some of this is a
little freaky but some of it's cool
some of it's cool that you can make a
[__] out of a lot of stuff
I think it's gonna be like how a bill
becomes a law remember that this is how
a bill becomes a lot I think it's gonna
have to be like this is how a [__]
becomes a [__] and they're gonna have
to talk about it because I don't want
people dying this is [__] horrible
I don't want people dying I want them to
figure out how to make better [__]
America
figure out how to make a better [__]
the [__] you got to get a better [__]
program for the kids gotta get a better
[__] program for the kids I do not want
my son's [__] infected
I do not want my son's [__] infected
and if you can't give my son
the [__] of his dreams
if you can't give my son listen to me
medical community
if you can't give my son a [__] he's
proud of
then I don't if I can't look at my son's
[__] without feeling a little bit of
Pride I don't want to deal I don't want
to be involved I don't want to be
involved cause that's sick
that's sick if you give my son a [__]
that's gross and green and diseased
I'm gonna be mad as a father
as a dad as a gay dad who adopted a son
who wants a [__] if we just follow this
to its logical conclusion me and my
husband have adopted a kid who ends up
being trans and we're dealing with it
and he comes home and he goes I gotta
puss and we're like great and then he's
like here it is and we're all looking at
his [__] uh at Christmas and his
sister's like oh my God that's gross put
it away and I'm like shut up he
accomplished that and then I look at it
and I'm like the lips are green
the lips of your [__] are green
and my son goes Dad shut up uh I think
they know what they're doing
and I'm like yeah maybe they do but like
maybe trust your old man a little bit
how about you trust your old man a
little bit on this
I used to you know before I decided I I
wanted cogs in my mouth I used to [__]
around the ladies and I never saw green
puss
I saw some flaps I didn't love down
there but I never saw Green Plus can you
trust your old man here and my husband's
going honey can you stop
honey can you stop it probably goes away
after a few days I'm like like they told
us the fireplace did we had to burn it
for eight hours and then the smell of
gas goes away I'm telling you you got a
problem here son you got a problem you
got a green puss and I want to take you
back and he goes nope [__] you I'm like
whatever
and then in two days he wakes up and
it's worse it's bad and I'm like I told
you and now my son's [__]
is being ravaged by necrotizing
fasciitis my son's vagina that I paid
for and he's proud of and we love we
love him my son's [__]
and I and then my neighbor says what's
going on and I go you're my son
his [__]
because I still but it's daughter but I
still can't it's hard for me to say
because I just keep forgetting because
he was my son for many years so I just
and he's okay with it my son is actually
okay with it he's like Dad I get it I'm
I'm very Chino but I get it's okay so I
that's what I'm talking and I go I'm not
talking to I'm like you know you know
Ralph's [__] is Scream any in my
neighborhood didn't you just get that
[__]
he just got that [__] but the thing is
you know we put Ralph on puberty blocker
so we didn't have enough penis tissue to
make the [__] they had to use his bowel
and they go of course
and then it's like you know in Long
Island someone's like you know Ralph's
having problems with his bowel [__]
this is a problem so I'm just letting
you know because my son also wants a
[__] and we're not doing it out of his
bow we're doing small intestine
Noel Tim Dillon's son had a bowel [__]
now he's got an advertising for shytus
so we're taking a small part of the
small intestine for our son's [__]
folks I know people might be offended by
this what I'm trying to say is that I
want better [__] I want better
[__] for the for the and I want
better [__] for the ladies that want
[__] if you want I want a hard thick
[__] for my daughter
if my door I wanna I want a beautiful
eight is a little too much but a seven
like a seven seven and a half uh nice
big [__] that's perfectly pink and thick
and round with two nice balls I want
that for my daughter
and if they don't know how to make a
[__] for my daughter
if my daughter comes home with a rotten
[__]
Because by the way folks this is what's
gonna happen you're not winning with
this stuff you're just not gonna win
your children are going to have [__]
and [__] for Christmas you're not
going to win you're probably not going
to win I don't know
I think I think it's a little wacky too
I think an adult should be able to do
what they want but it's just what it's
gonna you're gonna be getting your kids
[__] and [__] for Christmas there's
no way around it in 10 years you're
going to be giving your daughter a cow a
realistic [__] and she's gonna open it
and go thank you and you're gonna go
tomorrow we go down to the clinic and
get it sewed on and she's gonna be happy
because this is what it's gonna be and I
want the best for my kids so I want my
daughter to have a big thick [__] if she
wants
and I want my son to have a [__] if he
wants but we have to do better by the
kids with the with the materials we use
we have to use better materials
to make the [__]
and that's that's true this is real no
one should be getting angry at me I know
that people are going to get angry at
this and they're gonna go you know this
is actually a very serious issue and
you're trivializing it but I'm actually
not I'm actually saying you can't build
a [__] out of battles you got to use
better material to build my son's [__]
if my son wants a [__] I want him to
have a good one
I want it to be wet
I want it to be wet I want my son to
have a wet [__]
I want I want that you think I want my
son to have some draw like a dry puss
a dry [__]
I want my son's [__] to be so wet
that when he gets up from the chair on
Christmas dinner he leaves a trail like
a snail
like a snail
here's the thing can I even do the show
anymore because it's like can you
satirize any of this anymore where can
can you make jokes about it like could
what would what I don't even know
anymore like how do you how do you
heighten any of this
how do you make any of this you know how
do you make any of this funny without
you know I don't know anymore I truly
it's like we're it we're at a point
pretty soon we're like whatever I do
whatever you want to call it what I do
political satire I don't know what you
want to call it social commentary it's
almost becoming in pot the like it's
crazy to even talk about but I'm dead
serious about this
this is a tragedy and I want
I want everyone to be to do the right
thing
this is not good they say they got E
coli you know what salmonella I ate raw
cookie dough once and I went
am I gonna get salmonella from it
because of the egg
but this is what I mean about
risks we take in life I ate raw cookie
dough someone gets a puss
but it shouldn't be a risk you should be
able to transition in a healthy way and
it should be cost effective it shouldn't
be hard
it shouldn't be hard and your family
should be involved
your family should be involved in your
trip like you know what I mean
why wouldn't if you got a new [__]
you'd not show it like there was me and
this kid Dan we were on the road for a
while and we used to say this stuff all
the time and it was really funny we used
to say
we used to say the sentence where we go
don't be too embarrassed to ask your son
to see his [__] and this was we said
that's going to be the quote of like
2021. don't be too embarrassed to ask
your son to see his new [__]
and that's what I think that's the
advice I give to fathers
that's the advice I give to fathers
right now
you know your son has a [__] and you
know he's proud of it ask to see it
asked to see it you're not going to be
aroused you're not sick you're not a
sicko you just want to make sure that
they did the right thing by your son
because you took him in
and they're you know giving him a pus so
he can become your daughter
and you're like I'm cool with all that
I'm fine with all that go hey guys guys
I'm good with that I don't care by the
way I wouldn't care a lot of people
don't care if your son becomes a
daughter your daughter becomes so some
people care
but you want them to be healthy and
happy and have the best private parts
they can have that can't be
controversial it can't be controversial
to say I want my transgender son or
daughter to have the best fake private
parts they can have
and I'll pay for it I've got money I've
got money to buy a [__] for my daughter
but it's got to be good it can't kill
her
your [__] killed my son
[Music]
how many people are gonna have to run
into a medical facility and go
to Braveheart
thank you